[Musique]
Los Angeles quartier de Save central
l'un des quartiers les plus pauvres de
la ville ici habitent les Noirs les
latinos les banques traditionnelles ont
déserté les ghettos américains pour elle
un pauvre n’est pas un client sérieux
résultat un nouveau business florissant
occupe la place les premiers à avoir
exploité le filon ce sont les prêteurs
sur gaz aujourd'hui ils sont plus de
15000 aux États-Unis deux fois plus
qu'il y a 10 ans dans ces boutiques les
clients peuvent emprunter un petit peu
d'argent après avoir mis en caution à
bien personnel un monde piété à
l'américaine avec des taux d'intérêt
très élevés
regardez comme ça brille le patron c'est
lui David machkiri après une courte
carrière dans l'immobilier il est venu
s'installer dans le quartier dans les
années 60 david n'a pas honte de son
activité il la considère même comme un
service public
nous on est les banquiers du quartier
les banques ne veulent déjà pas prêter
500 ou 1000 dollars aux pauvres alors
pour ceux qui ont besoin de 50 dollars
ou de 100 dollars les banques leur
éclateraient
ils n'ont pas compté par une ils n'ont
que quelques bijoux en or
surtout les latinos
ils amènent beaucoup de bagues et de
bracelets
ils empruntent quelques centaines de
dollars
parmi les habitués de cette boutique
nous rencontrons Yvette Lévy employé
dans une crèche et mère de 6 enfants son
salaire ne lui permet pas de faire des
économies elle fait partie des working
tours les travailleurs pauvres ils sont
des millions aux États-Unis
aujourd'hui Yvette doit emprunter pour
payer son loyer elle a apporté toutes
ses bagues dans l'espoir d'obtenir un
prêt de 150 dollars
il vous donne un peu d'argent pour
chaque bague
elles ne veulent pas grand chose vous
savez 36 dollars pour toutes celles-ci
et 80 dollars pour celles en or avec des
petits diamants
c'est ma bague de mariage
ça c'est du bon matos
c'est le patron qui a la charge de
l'évaluation du prix des bijoux un
travail essentiel dans son commerce il
pèse lors de chaque bague et on mesure
minutieusement la taille des pierres
on prête l'équivalent du tiers du quart
de la valeur des bijoux
voyez sa bague je pourrais peut-être la
vendre 150 dollars
Yvette obtient 160 dollars selon elle
les bijoux ont coûté 1200 dollars à la
chasse soit plus de 7 fois la somme que
le prêteur surgage veut bien lui prêter
vous voyez il y a une date limite passer
cette date les bijoux leur appartiennent
immédiatement et ils ont le droit de les
vendre
ensuite il risque de se retrouver là
avec les autres bijoux vendu à un prix
bien supérieur à ce qu'il vous donne
pour votre gage
lors des pauvres est ici dans la salle
des coffres
c'est là que vous gardez les objets de
valeur
et ensuite ils sont ici dans le grand
coffre tout ça appartient ça
ne sera pas diffusé aux États-Unis
c'est pour votre protection
pour une télé
au moins 75 dollars non
les autres articles on les prend juste
pour faire plaisir aux clients
en espérant qu'un jour après nous avoir
apporté leur vélo leur télé
ils vendront leurre
c'est plus facile à gérer
en échange de ces bijoux Yvette a obtenu
un prêt de 160 dollars elle a désormais
quatre mois pour rembourser non pas 160
mais 195 dollars intérêt oblige
vous avez peur de perdre vos bijoux non
je reviens toujours dans les deux mois
mais souvent un mois plus tard j'ai à
nouveau des problèmes d'argent alors je
suis obligé de revenir mais pour
beaucoup de gens cela ne se passe pas
aussi bien vous avez vu il y a beaucoup
d'articles à vendre dans le magasin
beaucoup de gens font un emprunt et ne
reviennent pas chercher leurs articles
parce qu'il ne trouve pas d'argent pour
payer c'est ça ils ne peuvent pas payer
ou ce sont des articles volés qui sont
écoulés ici
vous savez nous sommes dans un quartier
pauvre
c'est pas la mairie riche ici
c'est difficile la vie et quand vous
êtes noir c'est encore plus dur
troquet de l'or contre quelques billets
ça commence à être dépassé aujourd'hui
pour exploiter la misère des pauvres il
y a beaucoup mieux les marchands de près
à très court terme
nous avons rencontré un homme d'affaires
qui a fait fortune en prêtant de
l'argent aux pauvres il s'appelle Jimbo
aujourd'hui son entreprise fast cache
compte une trentaine de boutiques en
Californie et au Nevada Jim adore
raconter sa succès story
[Musique]
j'ai arrêté mon doctorat d'histoire et
je suis venu m'installer dans le coin
j'ai ouvert un magasin d'alcool c'était
dans un quartier pauvre et il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui recevaient des
chèques d'allocations familiales et les
banques ne voulaient pas les encaisser
il se trouvait que cela faisait mauvais
genre d'avoir tous ces pauvres dans la
banque
donc j'avais des clients qui me
suppliaient d'encaisser leur chèque
contre de l'argent liquide et c'est
comme ça que tout a commencé
nous y voilà Jim nous fait visiter une
de ses succursales une sorte de mini
banque située dans un quartier pauvre de
la Silicon Valley en Californie pour
l'instant elle n'a jamais été attaquée
mais Jim et méfiant des milliers de
dollars en liquide sont gardés ici
nous avons plusieurs systèmes d'alarme
nous avons un système de surveillance
avec des caméras les glaçons par balles
ces murs font 25 cm d'épaisseur ils sont
remplis de sable
voyez ici cette matière cela ne fait que
quelques millimètres d'épaisseur mais
cela peut arrêter une balle de 357
Magnum
le service proposé par Jim s'appelle le
prêt jour de paye un prêt à très court
terme qui s'adresse à ceux qui ont un
travail mais un salaire de misère la
plupart n'ont pas assez d'argent pour
tenir jusqu'au prochain jour de paye
vous n'avez pas assez d'argent pour vos
cadeaux de Noël relax venez faire un
petit emprunt chez face cache vous voyez
le Père Noël il ne rentre même plus dans
la cheminée Jim se considère un peu
comme le Père Noël dans ce quartier
seule différence il ne fait pas vraiment
de cadeau lorsqu'il prête du liquide et
c'est comme ça qu'il s'est enrichi le
pré jour de paye est souvent le seul
recours pour ceux qui sont au pied du
mur pour régler une facture qui n'attend
pas ou pour tout simplement acheter de
quoi manger les clients font un emprunt
à très court terme souvent deux semaines
dont les taux d'intérêt varient la somme
empruntée entre 391 et 460%
ces gens empruntent de l'argent parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de quoi vivre les deux
prochaines semaines donc on leur donne
du liquide en échange d'un chèque de
caution daté de leur genre de paie on
les sélectionne en vérifiant que leur
compte en banque existe et on détermine
quelle somme on peut leur prêter
vous voyez cette femme elle s'appelle
Cassandra elle m'a fait un chèque de 300
dollars il y a deux semaines et je lui
avais donné 255 en liquide elle revient
aujourd'hui pour me rembourser en
liquide les 300 dollars pour que je lui
rende son chèque de caution maintenant
je vais pouvoir lui en faire un autre
quand voulez-vous rembourser votre
nouveau prêt Cassandra dans deux
semaines le 17 donc il y a un chiffre
de 300 dollars et je vais lui donner 255
dollars en liquide et dans deux semaines
elle viendra me racheter ce chèque c'est
comme ça que nous faisons notre bénéfice
nous donnons 255 dollars et on récupère
300 dollars
récapitulons en un mois cette cliente a
fait deux emprunts pour obtenir 510
dollars en cash elle va payer une
commission de 90 dollars cela représente
un taux d'intérêt annuel de 460%
pour moi c'est un peu effrayant de
penser qu'ils ont tellement besoin de
100 dollars 200 ou 250 dollars qu'ils
sont prêts à payer de telles commissions
tout ça pour tenir deux semaines
cela veut bien dire qu'aujourd'hui les
gens n'ont plus les moyens d'économiser
[Musique]
le siège social de face cache est situé
à San rosé en Californie les affaires
marchent très bien pour Jim qui
n'hésitent pas à afficher son goût de
l'argent sur les murs de son bureau
depuis la fin des années 70 il a ouvert
une nouvelle boutique par an mais ces
trois dernières années grâce au
développement du prêt jour de paye son
chiffre d'affaires a explosé c'est le
jackpot il a ouvert 13 nouveaux magasins
[Musique]
la vérité c'est que les gens ont besoin
et aiment se produit et ils ne se font
pas avoir
ce contrôler et qui abusent du système
mais c'est comme avec tous les autres
produits comme pour les drogues ou
l'alcool
vous trouvez toujours des gens qui
abusent
une accro du prêt jour de paye nous en
avons rencontré une Lisa et vendeuse
dans un supermarché accompagné de sa
soeur elle vient comme toutes les
semaines rembourser un prêt pour en
prendre un autre aujourd'hui pour
obtenir 200$ elle fait un chèque de 230
et elle nous confie qu'elle vit chez sa
mère et que c'est elle qui l'envoie
contracter ce prêt
[Musique]
pourquoi votre mère ne vient-elle pas
elle-même
peut-être qu'elle même a déjà fait un
emprunt elle a besoin de plus d'argent
donc c'est moi qui viens vous connaissez
le taux d'intérêt du PRAG vous venez de
contracter non pas vraiment je ne fais
pas attention à ça quand vous avez
vraiment besoin d'argent ça paraît pas
si mal
dans les quartiers pauvres la loi de
l'argent c'est la loi de la jungle le
marché explose et aucune loi n'encadre
les pratiques de ces banques
alternatives
[Musique]
ces cinq dernières années le nombre de
prêteurs jour de paye a explosé et
aujourd'hui en compte 22000 magasins aux
États-Unis plus que des McDonald's voici
le numéro 1 advance américain son
chiffre d'affaires a augmenté de 16%
cette année avant sa mère a refusé de
nous expliquer les raisons de son succès
mais ses publicités révèle sa stratégie
il faut déculpabiliser les plus pauvres
je dois avouer que quelques fois je me
retrouve à court d'argent avant le jour
de paye est-ce que ça fait deux mois
quelqu'un de mauvais non ça arrive à
tout le monde c'est la vie quand je
viens chez advance Américas personne ne
me fait culpabiliser personne ne me dit
eh vous avez de la chance qu'on soit là
c'est pas comme ma banque qui en plus me
facture des agios énormes quand je suis
à découvert
il se multiplie comme les rats et quand
vous en tuer un
un autre appareil chez le voisin
alors on fait des progrès on essaye de
faire passer des lois mais c'est
vraiment très difficile parce que ces
gens gagnent tellement d'argent
pour emprunter de plus grosses sommes
pour acheter une voiture par exemple les
pauvres ont accès eux aussi au crédit
les crédits faciles des offres
alléchantes en fait un piège
[Musique]
est un petit marchand de voiture
d'occasion dans le quartier mexicain de
Los Angeles
voici Carlos Sanchez Cruz un jeune
mexicain de 24 ans qui doit s'acheter un
véhicule afin de se rendre à son travail
un fast-food dans lequel il a trouvé un
emploi de cuisinier
Carlos aime bien cette petite voiture
mais il n'a pas assez d'argent pour
l'acheter
il décide donc d'avoir recours à un
crédit
un formulaire de demande de crédit
permis de conduire numéro de sécu et
référence de travail
ensuite nous allons envoyer ce
formulaire à la société de crédit et ils
vont se renseigner sur sa note de crédit
déterminer s'ils acceptent de le
financer et si oui à quel taux d'intérêt
on devrait avoir la réponse
c'est à ce moment-là que se met en
branle la machine du crédit américain
prenons les informations de Carlos la
société de crédit se met en liaison avec
un système informatique qui gère les
informations financières de 200 millions
d'individus 65000 milliards de fichiers
stockés analysés et accessibles en temps
réel nous sommes chez expérience l'une
des trois sociétés privées qui avec
l'aval de l'administration américaine
surveille et analyse la solvabilité
financière de 99% des consommateurs
américains l'endettement la ponctualité
dans le règlement des factures tout est
passé au peigne fin pour repérer les
mauvais payeurs et surtout pour donner à
chaque consommateur une note de bonne ou
mauvaise conduite intitulée note de
crédit
nous avons l'historique financier de
tous les consommateurs les informations
nous sont données par les banques et les
autres institutions financières ainsi
que par les fournisseurs de services
comme le téléphone ou l'électricité
voyez ici sur ce tableau nous pouvons
visualiser l'endettement des gens leur
demande de crédit et même leur
ponctualité dans les règlements de leur
facture tous ces éléments nous
permettent de calculer leur note de
crédit par exemple quelqu'un qui paye
ses factures en retard aura une note de
crédit plus basse que celui qui paye en
temps et en heure
autre exemple quelqu'un qui est endetté
lui aussi aura un score plus médiocre
que quelqu'un qui n'a pas de dette
[Musique]
une heure plus tard la société de
financement contacte Jim par téléphone
pour donner son accord ainsi que les
modalités du crédit oui allô
le prêt est-il accordé
oui à quelle taux d'intérêt
un prêt de 1150 dollars avec un taux
d'intérêt de 22%. c'est le contrat
proposé par la société de crédit
contacté par Jim un taux très élevé et
non négociable
business
c'est parce qu'il a une mauvaise note de
crédit et qu'en plus il est étranger
maintenant s'il était riche le taux
serait de 0%
votre note de crédit c'est ce qui vous
permet d'exister aux États-Unis et qui
sont généralement les gens qui ont une
mauvaise note de crédit
le classement moyenne et les pauvres
les gens veulent tout acheter même quand
ils n'ont pas les moyens
c'est ça l'Amérique
bien on va aller voir ta nouvelle
voiture enfin ta nouvelle voiture
d'occasion
le vendeur demandait 1650 dollars pour
la voiture avec le prix du crédit Carlos
va finalement payer 745 dollars
supplémentaires
d'un maxi campi
c'est comme ça pour les Mexicains
c'est n'importe quoi
Jim le vendeur de voiture n'a
personnellement rien à gagner dans la
transaction du crédit il ne touche pas
de commission il prend même un risque
c'est lui qui garantit le prêt
les frais de dossier du prêt et si le
client ne paye pas ces trois premières
mensualités nous devons racheter le prêt
ces sociétés de crédit joue gagnant à
tous les coups si votre note de crédit
est très mauvaise vous pouvez payer
jusqu'à 30 % d'intérêt c'est pour ça
qu'on dit que les riches s'enrichissent
et que les pauvres restent pauvres on
préfère qu'il reste à leur place
pénaliser les gens qui ont une mauvaise
note de crédit c'est la règle dans la
société américaine
nous partons à Washington pour
rencontrer Matthieu Fello un professeur
du prestigieux institut de recherche
booking pendant un an il a mené
l'enquête dans les quartiers pauvres son
étude révèle aujourd'hui l'une des
dérives du système financier américain
la note de crédit est utilisée pour
établir les taux d'intérêt des emprunts
mais également pour faire payer encore
plus cher les produits et les services
que consomme les pauvres des ghettos
américains
la plupart des gens qui viennent
d'habiter dans un quartier pauvre comme
celui-là ce disque dans ce genre
d'endroit la vie doit être moins cher
en fait c'est le contraire
en général les gens qui habitent ici ont
des notes de crédit inférieur à ceux qui
vivent dans les quartiers plus riches
et étant donné que les sociétés
d'assurance et que les sociétés de
crédit utilisent cette note pour fixer
leur tarifs les pauvres se retrouvent à
payer plus cher leurs assurances et les
remboursements d'emprunts de leur maison
tout ça parce que leur note de crédit
est inférieur
selon l'étude de Mathieu Fello la note
de crédit moyenne dans les quartiers
pauvres et de 18% inférieurs à celle des
classes moyennes une ségrégation par
l'argent qui ne dit pas son nom et qui
précipite les plus pauvres dans la
misère
on parle toujours de spirale de la
pauvreté moi je parle d'un dérèglement
du marché
les entreprises s'aperçoivent ou en tout
cas ont l'impression que cela coûte plus
cher de faire du commerce avec les
pauvres
donc pour se protéger elles augmentent
leur tarif
cela comme conséquence de faire payer
les pauvres un prix plus important pour
leurs produits de base et comme ils ont
moins les moyens de payer cela entraîne
un taux de faillite et d'impayés bien
plus important
et le résultat c'est que commercial avec
les pauvres revient plus cher c'est un
cercle vicieux basé quelquefois sur des
unités économiques et d'autres fois sur
des pratiques de prédateurs
la machine à fabriquer du score de
crédit dicte désormais sa loi aucun
Américain ne peut y échapper pour ceux
qui ont une bonne note les banques leur
ouvrent encore leurs portes et les
endroits un prêt de première classe très
avantageux un taux d'intérêt de moins de
7%. mais pour les mal notés de nombreux
organismes financiers proposent ce qu'on
appelle les prêts de deuxième classe des
prêts avec des taux d'intérêt annuels de
plus de 7% qui atteignent souvent 10%
voire plus
un marché en pleine expansion
aujourd'hui un consommateur américain
sur 4 a recours assez près de 2e classe
bonjour je m'appelle Nathan et je suis
un banquier prêt à vous aider même si
votre note de crédit est mauvaise on
était noyé sous les dettes on voulait
utiliser la plus-value de notre maison
pour s'en sortir nous on allait se faire
expulser de notre maison grâce à eux
nous avons obtenu l'argent dont nous
avions besoin en moins de 5 jours
c'est en regardant ce genre de publicité
que les épouses l'auteur ont contracté
un prêt de deuxième classe au taux
d'intérêt très élevé un piège dans
lequel tombe beaucoup d'Américains de la
classe moyenne lorsque survient le
moindre petit incident de la vie
jacqueline est agent de police son mari
est ouvrier en bâtiment mais il y a deux
ans suite à un accident il a dû quitter
son travail avec moins de revenus la
famille s'endette et pour s'en sortir
Jacqueline a mis sa maison en gage
ma maison était totalement payée ma
grand-mère avait fini de la payer il y a
très longtemps
regardez vous pouvez voir une photo de
moi avec ma grand-mère c'est une vieille
photo
aujourd'hui la maison de famille
n'appartient plus tout à fait à
Jacqueline en effet elle n'a obtenu un
prêt pour rembourser ses dettes qu'à
condition que sa maison servent de
garantie si elle ne rembourse pas son
prêt sa maison sera vendue mais le
remboursement de son prêt de deuxième
classe coûte cher à Jacqueline le taux
d'intérêt est trop élevé
je savais que ma note de crédit n'était
pas très bonne car je m'étais endetté en
m'occupant de ma famille avec le vendeur
de près je me sentais à l'aise surtout
après avoir entendu sa publicité à la
radio je pensais obtenir un service plus
personnalisé
il m'avait assuré que le taux d'intérêt
serait bas et je lui ai fait confiance
c'est seulement le jour de la signature
des contrats que je me suis rendu compte
que les intérêts étaient très élevés
mais à ce stade je ne pouvais plus rien
faire
il fallait que j'éponge des dettes
immédiatement
ils ne m'ont pas laissé porte de sortie
une fois les contrat signés il n'y a
plus rien à faire Jack line officier de
police connaît la loi aujourd'hui elle
s'en mord les doigts car les termes de
son emprunt sont effarants au bout du
compte pour emprunter moins de 33000
dollars elle devra rembourser un total
de
96135 dollars dont
63280 dollars d'intérêt
j'étais tellement furieuse contre eux
que je ne préfère pas vous dire ce que
j'avais envie de leur faire mais bon je
me suis calmée et j'ai remis tout ça
dans les mains de Dieu
cela ne devrait jamais arriver ce genre
de chose jamais et à personne ça vous
démolisse je me suis débarrassé de mes
agios et de mes pénalités un seul
paiement par mois et il s'occupe du
reste
[Musique]
les emprunts de seconde classe avec leur
taux d'intérêt élevé font le bonheur du
marché financier américain le chiffre
d'affaires de ce type de prêt a explosé
ces 10 dernières années pour passer de
91 à 516 milliards de dollars c'est à
Wall Street que les sociétés de crédit
vont chercher les investisseurs qui
financent les prêts de deuxième classe
mais prêter au pauvres au mauvais payeur
c'est considéré comme risqué des
sociétés sont spécialisées dans ce qu'on
appelle ici la sécurisation des
investissements
nous sommes ici chez greenich financial
ce géant de la finance fait partie des
leaders sur le marché de la sécurisation
des emprunts de deuxième classe avec un
volume de 183 milliards de dollars en
Peter Di Martino et banquier
d’investissement sa mission éliminer
tous les risques grâce à des outils
financiers très sophistiqués
[Musique]
de deuxième classe sont plus risqués
pour les investisseurs que les prêts de
première classe mais pas du tout
en fait notre procédé de sécurisation
mais en place un mécanisme de protection
financière qui permet de protéger les
investisseurs du marché des prêts de
deuxième classe
une fois ce travail accompli nos actions
générées par les prêts de deuxième
classe on le même taux de rentabilité
que celle générée par les prêts de
première classe c'est ça la sécurisation
et qui finance cette sécurisation les
investisseurs ou les consommateurs je
préfère ne pas répondre à cette question
Peter ne nous en dira pas plus les
détails de la sécurisation de la mise en
confiance des investisseurs sont
jalousement gardés par Wall Street et
pour cause ils ne sont pas toujours
avoir
pour en savoir plus nous avons rencontré
un expert de ce système opaque Patricia
MacCoy et professeur à l'Université de
Hartford spécialisée dans le droit
financier elle est l'auteur d'un rapport
sur le rôle de Wall Street dans le
développement des prêts de deuxième
classe
les investisseurs obtiennent déjà un
taux de rentabilité très élevé pour un
risque minime
mais comme il se disent méfiant il
demande un taux de rentabilité encore
plus élevé
et ça fait donc augmenter le taux
d'intérêt des prêts de deuxième classe
pour les emprunteurs
pour moi c'est juste une façon
d'exploiter les gens qui ont le moins
d'argent et surtout leur faire payer
plus que ce qui est nécessaire pour
couvrir les risques financiers encourus
par les investisseurs
et plus les gens sont désespérés plus
vous pouvez les faire payer
un Philadelphie le désespoir on connaît
cette ville est un des hauts lieux de la
pauvreté aux États-Unis la précarité et
l'exclusion sociale frappe plus de 20%
d'une population en majorité noire à
cela s'ajoute un nouveau phénomène celui
des petits propriétaires qui ne peuvent
plus payer leur retraite et qui sont
expulsés par les sociétés de crédit
un Philadelphie une moyenne de 1000
personnes par mois perdent leur maison
nous avons rencontré Dany quelques jours
avant son expulsion de sa petite maison
dans le ghetto sud de Philadelphie ces
problèmes ont commencé il y a 5 ans
lorsqu'il a perdu son emploi suite à une
blessure il est toujours dit dans
l'incapacité de rembourser un emprunt de
25000 dollars
j'ai peur de perdre cette maison c'est
tout ce que j'ai jamais possédé dans ma
vie je l'ai acheté quand je me suis
marié
je ne voulais pas reprendre un emprunt
c'est ma femme qui voulait faire des
réparations
en ce moment je dois 25000 dollars
mais avec les frais d'avocat de 15000
plus les frais de mise en vente de la
maison par le shérif j'en suis à 40
pour eux c'est un bonheur les procédures
d'expulsion c'est un commerce lucratif
au dépend des gens
Dany s'est réfugié dans la dernière
pièce habitable de la maison il est
désespéré le remboursement de sa dette
est devenu insurmontable
ce qui vous assassine ce sont les
intérêts et les pénalités pour les
retards de règlement c'est ruineux
quand vous vous retrouvez comme ça do au
mur c'est la déprime qui vous gagne vous
devenez un hermite l'angoisse vous gagne
avec les factures qui continuent à
arriver vous avez la sensation qu'il n'y
a pas d'issue il y a de quoi se suicider
c'est le shérif à Philadelphie qui à la
charge de vendre aux enchères les
maisons des particuliers en faillite au
profit des sociétés de crédit
aujourd'hui plus de 900 maisons vont
être vendues en quelques heures nous ne
pouvons pas entrer dans la salle mais
nous avons tout de même plissé un micro
à l'intérieur et une maison c'est vite
vendu écoutez
fin mille dollars 20
000 dollars
à 35000 dollars
40000 dollars
45000 une fois deux fois 45000 dollars à
juger à l'avocat en rouge
le shérif John Green est celui qui fait
respecter la loi mais depuis quelques
mois une partie de ces bureaux a été
transformée en agence immobilière
presque un second métier pour le sheriff
les propriétés sont vendues à un bon
prix donc les gens qui cherchent à faire
une bonne affaire viennent à l'avant du
shérif
d'un côté vous avez les gens qui perdent
leur maison et qui sont expulsés
vous avez des gens qui obtiennent des
propriétés un bon prix
il répare les maisons c'est bon pour la
stabilité de la communauté
en espérant que les nouveaux acquéreurs
n'auront pas contracté un pas deuxième
classe oui mais même s'ils ont un prêt
de deuxième classe il faut bien
comprendre qu'ils obtiennent une
propriété à un prix inférieur au marché
donc ils font immédiatement un bénéfice
grâce à ce prêt deuxième classe
les bureaux du shérif font payer 1200
dollars à toutes les personnes dont la
maison est mise en vente une taxe qui
rapporte un million de dollars par mois
et qui déclenche la polémique car aux
États-Unis le shérif est élu par ses
concitoyens c'est un homme politique
cette taxe des expulsions a déclenché la
colère de John Doud
le rêve des gens est jeté par la fenêtre
John est directeur d'une association
caritative qui organise régulièrement
des manifestations devant les bureaux du
shérif
l'argent est collecté par le chéri et il
utilise pour faire de la publicité
partout dans tous les journaux de la
ville les quotidiens les hebdos à la
radio et ses acolytes ramassent une
commission de 15%
vous voulez dire que l'argent va au
bureau du shérif
qui est dirigée par son chef de campagne
le chérif vous dirait que ces publicités
aident à vendre les maisons pour la
vente aux enchères mais moi je pense que
c'est surtout un bon moyen d'arroser les
journaux pour obtenir leur faveur
et c'est un bon moyen de faire du fric
sur le plan national en moyenne 64
000 personnes perdent leur maison chaque
mois ce nombre d'expulsions est tout
simplement sans précédent dans
l'histoire des États-Unis
afin de mieux comprendre les raisons de
ce désastre économique et social l'état
de Pennsylvanie a commandé une étude à
ira Goldstein un expert dans le
financement immobilier
[Musique]
voici la carte de Philadelphie avec ici
les quartiers avec les plus forts taux
d'expulsion
dans les trois quarts des cas ce sont
des gens qui ont contracté les
empreintes de deuxième classe
les gens ne peuvent tout simplement pas
faire face à leur paiement c'est
vraiment un énorme commerce
le volume des prêts de deuxième classe a
augmenté de façon exponentielle depuis
le milieu des années 90
à la même vitesse que les taux
d'expulsion oui elle a la même vitesse
les quartiers avec les taux les plus
importants sont en général ceux dans
lesquels il y a une majorité de noirs
un Philadelphie la communauté noire et
la plus pauvre c'est la cible numéro 1
des marchands de près de deuxième classe
et parfois il n'hésite pas à abuser des
plus faibles
n'hésitez pas monsieur Bronson un
soudeur à la retraite de 65 ans s'est
fait séduire par une publicité à la
radio notre société a des assurances et
assure les prêts immobiliers pour les
gens avec une bonne ou une mauvaise note
de crédit notre société contracte des
prêts avec des églises sans bien
comprendre les termes du contrat
monsieur Bronson s'est fait vendre un
prêt de 31800 dollars un taux de 12,45%
sur 30 ans
au moment de la signature il ne savait
même pas que le prêt hypothèque et sa
maison
ils avaient l'air gentil je me suis dit
je vais leur faire confiance
je pensais faire un simple emprunt pas
un emprunt hypothécaire sur ma maison je
ne comprenais rien à tous les papiers
qu'il me présentait il me disait signer
ici signer là je n'avais même pas le
temps de lire
et ensuite c'était trop tard ouais
beaucoup trop tard
vous savez quand cette histoire a
commencé je faisais 60 kg
et maintenant je n'empêche plus que 49
et je continue à plonger
je décline chaque jour un petit peu plus
pour se sortir d'affaires monsieur
Bronson a trouvé de l'aide
une organisation gouvernementale dont la
fonction est de faire respecter
l'égalité raciale dans l'État de
Pennsylvanie lui a envoyé cet avocat
Charles neyers l'avocat a trouvé un
argument juridique de poids il accuse
ceux qui ont vendu le prêt de Monsieur
Bronson d'avoir pratiqué une politique
commerciale raciste
[Musique]
pour protéger la personne ou lutter
contre le racisme et ses lois sont
beaucoup plus punitives que les lois qui
protègent les gens des prêts abusifs
notre commission était capable de
prouver que ceux qui faisaient ce genre
de crédit ciblés manifestement les
Afro-Américains et nous avons prouvé
qu'il faisait leur publicité en
utilisant seulement des médias
afro-américains notamment leur show
radio sur les grandes ondes
la société de crédit la société des
frères macglone a été condamné en
première instance à une suspension de
licence mais surtout à une amende de 910
000 dollars les maglotes en fait appel
la peine est suspendue en attendant une
décision définitive de la cour d'appel
de Pennsylvanie
suite au refus répéter des maglones de
nous accorder un rendez-vous nous
décidons de rentrer dans leur bureau
avec une caméra cachée
Anthony maglon se monte brièvement et la
surprise il est lui-même afro-américain
vous savez pourquoi on est là oui et on
m'a conseillé de ne pas vous parler ah
bon on vous a conseillé de pas nous
parler oui c'est mon avocat qui m'a dit
de ne pas vous parler vous m'obligez à
me répéter appelez donc mon avocat
puisque vous avez son numéro
nous avons appelé l'avocat des maglones
plusieurs fois
et il a finalement bien voulu nous
recevoir
si je comprends bien la position de
cette agence gouvernementale elle nous
dit que ces gens ne sont pas aptes à
prendre leur propre décision quand il
s'agit de contracter ou non un prêt
je pense que c'est une erreur si ce
genre de jugement était confirmé par les
tribunaux alors on retournerait à la
situation des années 70 et 80 à l'époque
où les Noirs étaient incapables
d'emprunter
je dis les Noirs mais en fait je voulais
dire les pauvres
ça ce sont des photos de famille
de souvenirs
le temps presse pour Monsieur Bronson le
verdict de la cour d'appel qui
condamnerait définitivement les maglones
arrivera probablement trop tard
j'ai reçu les papiers de la procédure
d'expulsion
il va falloir qu'on trouve un endroit
pour habiter
et à mon âge je ne peux pas tout
recommencer
dans la société américaine ce genre
d'affaires ne fait jamais grand bruit
40 ans après avoir obtenu leur droit
civique les Noirs restent les plus
touchés par la grande misère 1 sur 4 vis
sous le seuil de pauvreté et leur taux
de chômage est deux fois plus important
que celui des blancs
une inégalité considérée comme du
racisme économique qui met en colère des
leaders noirs comme Michael Zazoun un
ancien Black Panther qui vit dans le
ghetto de Los Angeles
moi je vous parle d'un racisme
sophistiqué soutenu par un système
économique qui a les pouvoirs
d'instaurer les politiques racistes qui
existent dans ce pays
que ce soit dans la police dans le
système judiciaire dans les entreprises
ou dans les grands groupes qui dirigent
ce pays
il y en a qui dit c'est même pas un pays
c'est juste une immense entreprise
je crois qu'on doit vraiment prendre
conscience de l'impact de ces grands
groupes sur les prolétaires et sur
l'ensemble des pauvres que ce soit des
femmes des latinos des noirs ou des
vieux
[Musique]
un wall Street les affaires continuent
comme si de rien n'était
les actions générées par les prêts de
deuxième classe enrichissent les
investisseurs et on est bien loin de ce
préoccuper des conséquences sociales de
l'exploitation des pauvres nous
retrouvons Peter monsieur sécurisation
au fait quelqu'un l'a mise au courant
des expulsions et des procès en cours
dites moi c'est prêt à fort taux
d'intérêt entraînent souvent des
expulsions quelquefois des procès
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
de communication lui conseille d'arrêter
l'interview
[Musique]
un Wall Street le seul qui va finalement
accepter de répondre à cette question
tabou c'est Robert Paulsen lui travaille
pour une société spécialisée dans la
notation des prêts de deuxième classe
[Musique]
nous analysons le taux de faillite et
d'expulsion et cela nous inquiète quand
il devient trop élevé
d'expulsions augmente ou pas ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de savoir s'il y a une
diminution des profits pour nos
investisseurs
les propriétés ont pris de la valeur les
pertes sont minimisées pour les
actionnaires donc les investisseurs sont
protégés d'une façon générale oui
à travers les principaux investisseurs
comblés par le marché les banques les
sociétés d'assurance les fonds de
pension c'est finalement tout le système
financier qui profite des revenus
générés par les empreintes de deuxième
classe et tant pis si les perdant sont
toujours les mêmes les pauvres
un jour on va découvrir l'étendue de ce
scandale
et le Parlement sera bien obligé de
changer les lois cela n'arrivera pas
cette année mais un jour cela devra
arriver
peut-être avec la société américaine va
éclater Americ West c'est le plus gros
fournisseur de prêt de deuxième classe
du pays une part de marché de plus de
20% un chiffre d'affaires de 80
milliards de dollars en 2004
Americ West a refusé toute nos demandes
d'interview et pour cause cette société
fait l'objet de 25 enquêtes fédérales et
d'une multitude de procédures engagées
par des groupes de consommateurs
[Musique]
je suis spécialiste des prêts je suis là
pour réaliser vos rêves
le fear sponsor du rêve américain
le rêve américain se retraité de 76 ans
n'y croient plus
[Musique]
tout commence il y a un an et demi un
vendeur d'Amérique ouest réussi à vendre
à Monsieur Bailey un crédit hypothécaire
de 350 000 dollars chaque mois il devra
rembourser 3600 dollars seul problème
monsieur Bailey vit avec une retraite de
900 dollars par mois après une faillite
presque immédiate monsieur Bailey
s'affole et s'enfuit de sa maison qui
est vendu deux mois plus tard par Americ
West
j'aurais dû demander de l'aide mais
j'avais trop honte pour demander quoi
que ce soit
ils m'ont vraiment trompé vous savez ils
ont trafiqué mon dossier
vraiment
sur toute la ligne
quelques semaines après avoir quitté sa
maison monsieur Bailey prévient son
jeune neveu qui ignorait tout de
l'histoire en consultant le dossier du
prêt John soupçonne tout de suite
l'escroquerie
le premier élément que j'ai trouvé
bizarre c'était le montant du prêt même
si le prix de sa maison a augmenté
depuis les années 70
lui prêter 357000 dollars ça fait
beaucoup
ensuite j'ai vu à combien l'organisme de
crédit évaluer ses revenus et là j'ai vu
que c'était trop alors qu'il a juste une
petite retraite
je me suis dit mais qui lui a vendu un
prêt pareil
c'est que Peterson un avocat de San
Francisco familier avec les tactiques
douteuses d'Amérique ouest qui reprend
la ferme en main
[Musique]
découvre immédiatement des irrégularités
dans le dossier
[Musique]
a été de 357000 dollars avec un taux
d'intérêt de 12% qui pouvait ensuite
grimper jusqu'à 18 %
savait que ce monsieur serait incapable
de payer ses mensualités
Americ West savait aussi qu'il finirait
par l'expulser et lui prendre sa maison
acheter avec sa femme en 1972 sa maison
avait pris une forte plus-value environ
140 000 dollars
l'avocat s'est rendu compte que le
vendeur d'Amérique ouest n'avait pas
hésité à falsifier les documents
regardez dans notre jargon c'est ce
qu'on appelle une déclaration de
ressources elle dit je reçois 4000
dollars de loyer par mois et elle est
censée avoir été signée par Monsieur
Bellay le 19 novembre 2003
en réalité ce document est un faux
monsieur Bailey n'a jamais écrit ni
signé ce document et je suis capable de
le prouver
face au dossier de l'avocat Americ West
préfère éviter le procès la société
n'aime pas ce genre de publicité après
avoir fait vendre la maison pour se
faire rembourser l'emprunt Americo s
décide donc de racheter la maison et de
la rendre à Monsieur Bailey en lui
versant en prime de copieux dommages et
intérêts
bonjour quand on veut voir à la maison
happy and donc pour se retraité qui sans
aide serait toujours dire ruiner et sans
domicile
[Musique]
ils ont offert un arrangement très
intéressant pour vous desdommager je
suis content qu'on est plus récupéré
votre maison après un an vous devez être
heureux d'être à la maison oui c'est
formidable être à la maison
en fait on sait très bien que Monsieur
Bailey n'est pas un cas isolé
monsieur Bellay est un parfait exemple
du type de gens cibler par Americ West
et les autres fournisseurs de près de 2e
classe à tout abusif
dans notre dossier nous avions plusieurs
autres témoignages de victimes des gens
qui ont vécu les mêmes épreuves que
Monsieur Bailey
en tout cas pour prouver que ces
pratiques sont monnaies courantes chez
Americ West
le 24 juin 2005 la société américaine
fait la une du Los Angeles Time qui
titres sur le plus important procès de
l'histoire intentée contre une société
de crédit la procédure a été engagée par
plusieurs milliers de victimes qui
accusent Americ West de discrètement
changer les termes des contrats de
crédit avant leur signature ce procès
qui se tient à Sainte Matéo en
Californie né d'ailleurs qu'une
formalité la société américaine à d'ores
et déjà annoncé qu'elle s'engageait à
verser 50 millions de dollars de
dédommagement aux victimes
[Musique]
le premier à sortir de l'audience c'est
Naïm McCarthy l'avocat des plaignants
une bonne journée pour lui puisqu'il
vient d'empocher une commission de 10
millions de dollars 10 millions silences
compris puisque sous la pression
d'Amérique ouest les deux parties se
sont formellement engagés à ne plus
parler à la presse
quelques minutes plus tard c'est
l'avocat d'americ Quest qui fait sa
sortie et lui non plus n'est pas très
bavard je peux vous poser une question
nous nous sommes engagés à ne pas parler
dans le contrat de négociation et je
dois le respecter je ne peux pas parler
à la presse c'est une bonne affaire pour
remercier
parler à cet homme il travaille pour
Americ West je peux vous poser une
question non on vous enverra une
déclaration officielle
le seul qui accepte finalement de nous
parler c'est cet avocat iron Mayer
lui-même impliqué dans une autre
procédure contre Americ West il a été
entendu à cette audience comme simple
témoin sa parole est donc libre
de 2 milliards de dollars
il y a des lois qui protègent les gens
contre ce genre de pratique
mais pas assez
la raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
plus de lois pour protéger les gens
c'est que ces institutions financières
forment des lobbies très puissants
tous les plus grands donateurs du parti
républicain sont des institutions
financières ou plutôt les milliardaires
qui les dirigent
le meilleur exemple c'est Roland Arnold
le propriétaire d’amery Quest
le fondateur d'Amérique ouest celui
Roland Arnold avec une fortune
personnelle estimée à 3 milliards de
dollars il est l'un des hommes les plus
riches des États-Unis une fortune qu'il
met au service de plusieurs hommes
politiques Arnold Schwarzenegger en a
profité plus d'un million de dollars
pour payer sa campagne au poste de
gouverneur ont été donnés par Americ
West
en 2004 Roland Arnold a été le grand
collecteur de fonds de la campagne
présidentielle de George Bush et pour le
récompenser le président des États-Unis
a récemment offert à Roland Arnold un
poste d'ambassadeurs en Hollande
seul souci un ambassadeur des États-Unis
doit être confirmé par le Sénat dans ce
document vidéo qui montre une réunion du
Comité des affaires étrangères un petit
groupe de sénateurs est chargé de
valider les différentes candidatures
proposées par le président américain
aujourd'hui Roland Arnault est interrogé
par deux sénateurs démocrates opposés à
sa nomination Barack Obama le seul
sénateur noir des États-Unis et Paul
sarbane
si je comprends bien
Americ West fait l'objet d'une multitude
d'enquêtes fédérales dirigée par les
procureurs
et dans combien d'états je ne sais plus
très bien j'ai plusieurs chiffres 25 30
c'est bien ça
il y a plusieurs chiffres on ne sait pas
exactement combien
donc l'essentiel de ces investigations
portent sur vos pratiques commerciales
excessives et même de falsifier les
documents
à cause de tout ça des gens ont été
trompés
dans certains cas
votre envie de régler ces histoires
devraient aujourd'hui être absolument
sans limites
dans les années 80 quand j'ai fondé
cette société
contrairement aux banques on a permis à
toute une catégorie de gens qui avaient
des mauvaises notes de crédit
d'emprunter
c'est vrai on a eu des problèmes
mais on les a corrigés
vous savez quand vous avez 16000
employés
des accidents peuvent arriver
de toute façon si je suis confirmé au
poste d'ambassadeurs de Hollande
je me retire des affaires
je ne trouve pas satisfaisant de vous
entendre dire que vous allez vous
contenter de vous en aller et que vous
allez laisser à d'autres le soin
d'arranger tout ça ne croyez-vous pas
que vous devriez fixer de nouvelles
règles avant de partir la nomination de
Roland Arnal a été confirmée par le
Sénat quelques semaines plus tard entre
temps Americ West s'est engagé à payer
325 millions de dollars pour dédommager
les victimes tout est donc rentré dans
l'ordre et Americ West a lancé sa
nouvelle campagne publicitaire on
sponsorisant la prochaine tournée des
Rolling Stones
pendant ce temps le système économique
est financier américain continue à
fabriquer des pauvres des surendettés
des expulsés en un an plus d'un million
d'Américains sont passés sous le seuil
de pauvreté
[Musique]